hey liz i'm well how are you
good good pleasure to speak with you
today likewise
excellent and i love this very very nice
blue background you feel
isn't it so blue yeah it's the bluest
um and so to start off i wanted to ask
about what were kind of the origins of
this for you
so i was looking back at my first notes
when i
wrote down this idea back in 2015 uh
i became a dad that same year and i
think
becoming a dad probably kind of forced
me to take stock of my life and
and i feel just incredibly grateful for
so many things in my life i've found a
partner that i love so much and we have
our kids and i have two wonderful
parents and
i get to do work that's meaningful to me
and i'm healthy and safe and
you know i have so much to be grateful
for but i'd also be lying if i told you
i was just
happy a hundred percent of the time i i
just don't know if that's
human to to be that way or at least it's
it's not
for me and um and so you know i wanted
to tell a story about a guy that's
doing his best and and does have a lot
to be grateful for and
and he and he's happy sometimes but he'd
be lying if he told you he's happy all
the time
and and he's he's trying to figure it
out and uh
that's that's mr corman you know not
being happy can feel sad
it can feel anxiety inducing it can also
be funny if you have
i don't know a certain sense of humor
which i seem to have so
um that's that's where the humor comes
from what about him being the teacher
uh unlocked the idea for you i've always
admired teachers a great
great deal uh if i could wave a magic
wand
i would live in a world where teachers
are the ones
more than entertainers where teachers
are the ones that are getting
celebrated and valorized and who are
making lots of money and
and where all of us are talking all the
time about this amazing teacher that
amazing teacher like
i think that would be a healthier world
and uh i've had some incredible teachers
in my life i've always
been drawn to that as a profession
something i would still
hope that i get to do at some point in
my life and so i really wanted to
to play a teacher that's fun
and you got to work with you got to work
with kids which is
a new experience i'm sure well it's
funny because you know when i i
i'm playing a fifth grade teacher who
has students who are 10 and 11
i was acting when i was 10 11. so that
was another reason why i was excited to
play a teacher was i was really excited
to work with young actors like that
i remember being a young actor like that
and there's some really great
performances from super young actors in
mr corman
absolutely i mean i've seen the whole
season uh which was a lot of fun
and oh thanks for watching the whole
thing of course
um and i'm i'm very curious uh because
very there you know there's a very clear
fight you know
it was known before going i knew before
going in that production
uh you know shifted during you know
shutdown
but i wasn't expecting the story to
change so much and i'm curious what the
original
what your original plan for for the for
the show was
before before pandemic happened
yeah well it's it's largely similar it's
so the first seven episodes of the show
are the same that we
wrote um and then the last three
episodes are set during the pandemic
and there's only one whole new script
that we wrote after the pandemic arrived
and that's episode eight
where you see the pandemic arrive and
then episode 9 and 10 are
substantially similar to what we had
written they're just now
set during the pandemic which kind of
gives them an extra
i think a bit of intrigue um
but uh yeah so there was just one script
that was actually
mostly said at school that we just
couldn't shoot
because we couldn't shoot at the school
anymore
um and so that one had to go
unfortunately
and it we replaced it with what's now
episode
eight which is uh yeah now kind of like
this work of historical fiction about
this thing that we all
just went through i mean that is like
an eerie part of this whole experience
just knowing that you know the stuff
that we've been making
and watching for the last year is going
to be this own like you know real-time
document
of what it's been like it's funny you
know i
i feel like for a lot of shows you can
ignore the pandemic and i
totally get and respect that our show
is sort of at its core trying to feel
real
about real life in today's
real world it's it's not so much
like about escapism and and so it didn't
feel right
to just try to avoid or ignore the
pandemic
and um you know i think three episodes
is good
just just the last three episodes i feel
like that's probably enough for sure
yeah that's enough
you have a really great collection of
you know guest stars
uh across the season uh you know were
there
were there people that you just knew
automatically if i ever make something
like this i just want to have them
involved or were there people you wrote
stuff specifically for
well when i told my mom that deborah
winger was gonna play
my mom she was i i'm not exaggerating
she was moved
because deborah winger is a meaningful
artist you know i mean like let's face
it the
the history of hollywood's portrayal
of female characters um is is not great
and and deborah winger decades ago
was was already saying i i'm not going
to be
reduced to a plot device or
you know a pretty thing i'm going to
play a full human being and she does it
so
brilliantly and i just think she's
such a wonderful artist and i'm i'm
honored and delighted that she played my
mom and mr corman yeah she got she
h you you got it she was definitely like
the face of the
documentary searching for deborah winger
like it's great to see her back on
screen
i'm not familiar with that documentary
i'll have to look for it
yeah it's a it's about ageism in
hollywood oh wow
that's exactly what i was just talking
about jeez i have to really i have to
watch this documentary
yeah it's pretty good um you know
normally i would ask this question about
like you know why did you direct certain
episodes
but i want to get your answer on why you
don't direct every episode of this
season
well there's a wonderful director who
directed a couple of the episodes um
like you said i directed eight and she
directed two aurora guerrero
is her name um so she directed the the
second episode which is
um you know this character suffers
through a certain amount of anxiety
and um i wanted someone else to be
directing me
for that um when you're directing you
have to
keep your eye on so many things and i
knew that for that episode i wanted to
be able to kind of
lose myself and and just go
wholeheartedly into
the emotions the character was feeling
and aurora was
such a wonderful guide and um
and director uh doing that um
and uh and yeah she's just a wonderful
collaborator in general
i i know you have a long-standing
relationship with ryan johnson
have you figured out a way to sneak into
knives out too yet
we'll see i hope so excellent well thank
you so much for your time it's been a
pleasure
yeah great talking to you thank you liz